hi welcome to the hero daily my name is
dimas and this is uh the place that you
want to be if you love marvel news
updates rumors and leaks as well as
giving you those marvel updates i am
going to be donating 25 of my video
revenue to a charity that my subscribers
choose see nowadays it's hard for people
to donate money even though they want to
i personally don't have much money and i
would love to use this as a way to help
out charities that i do love see for one
i love charities like st juice
children's hospital aspca which is the
american society for the prevention of
cruelty to animals as well as the
american heart association those are my
favorites but i will ask you guys what
yours are and then we'll put it to a
vote every week where you guys decide
who we donate to and i'll just upload a
video just showing you guys that you did
contribute to the donation to a great
charity and you know what and together
we can all be the superheroes that save
the world
thank you so much for your time i really
appreciate it please subscribe watch my
videos like comment
and i trust me this will be
something you do not want to miss out on
thank you so much